this morning we continued our six-month
investigation into sexual harassment and
assault allegations at the US Air Force
Academy you're seeing it only on CBS
this morning yesterday we shared stories
of more than a dozen current and former
cadets they say they were assaulted at
the school and faced retaliation for
reporting it this morning we aired our
interview with the Academy's former top
official on sexual assault
she told us she believes the Academy
undercounts sexual assault cases over
the past 10 years there have been 287
sexual assault reports made by cadets at
the academy that includes 32 reports
last school year joining us now is the
Air Force Academy's new superintendent
Lieutenant General Jay Silverio general
thank you for being here thank you for
traveling all the way from Colorado
Springs to talk about this we appreciate
it as you know we spoke to cadets who
said they were assaulted they were
harassed even raped and then that they
faced retaliation for reporting it how
do you respond to those cadets
well first off Nora Gail John thank you
for having me it's important that I'm
here to talk about this important topic
and to do this in person face to face
I'm disgusted by those reports I mean
just like you I mean I'm disgusted by
that I'm I'm a parent I've I have two
children that are in their early 20s
that that that went to college there
their mother my wife we'd be horrified
if that happened to one of our children
so I'm just as disgusted by that that
that those assaults happen to those
people just as anyone else well what
about the fact that they tried to report
this to take action they believed they
were retaliated against by their
commanders at the academy so Nora I'm
responsible as a superintendent of the
Academy for the climate and the culture
at the Air Force Academy and I've
committed myself from the very beginning
it's been very clear that I expect the
cadets and the faculty and the staff to
treat each other with respect and
dignity and I've enforced that from the
very beginning but it's also about
accountability and so the office that
was providing the support and I know you
interviewed someone who was in charge of
that office it's about the
accountability of that office and so
there were some allegations that she
about the office but she was in a
leadership role in that office and while
I respect her service in that office
there are standards in that office that
we needed to maintain you ran the piece
about general Johnson that she initiated
the investigation she had to take action
because our cadets deserve the very best
the charissa Beasley says though that
when she brought it to the attention
that it was minimized that the severity
that that that the people were not
believed to nor his point where she said
that they were things were undercut that
people sort of minimalized people at the
academy normalized because it sounds
like she did bring it to the attention
but nothing was done I think that's the
answer we're trying to get from you so
she did she did bring a number of items
to attention which was part of the
investigation and there were a couple
dozen witnesses that were part of the
investigation but I think it's important
that you don't just focus on Teresa
Beasley in that office we have a number
of layers of care that we have for
cadets they have mental health
professionals they have student
counseling services they have chaplains
that are available for cadets of faith I
mean we have all of our commanders are
trained they have an accredited master's
degree in counseling from the University
of Colorado system so cadets get support
the way that they want to get support
not the way that someone in an
individual also thinks they should get
one of the people Norah talked to said
you go there because you want to protect
your country and they don't protect you
that's a pretty extraordinary statement
what you've talked about accountability
what exactly are you doing so that no
cadet would ever be in a position to
have be able to make that kind of a
statement well since I've been there
I've made my stance on the whole journey
I've been there since August since I've
made my stance on on culture and climate
very clear additionally I have held
everyone to a high standard last month
we we removed a cadet that for sexual
assault last month we also removed a
cadet for racial slurs
I've also held out one of our athletic
teams to a very high standard and and
suspended some coaches and players for
not meeting standards so I think what's
important is my role is to set that
climate and set that culture at the
Force Academy as we reported yesterday
two attacks on a trail near the campus
were called physical attacks but were
actually violent rapes why didn't the
Academy warn cadets when that happened
no the Academy did warn cadets the
Academy did an exhaustive investigation
of that trail and of that incident over
80 witnesses were called the
investigation was over months a number
of forensics about when people arrived
and left left the area and then we added
a number of measures and protective
measures onto the trail so the Academy
took that very seriously well in fact
it's my reporting here that the only
public announcement made in the wake of
these attacks was on new sofas Facebook
page and that the the academies
essentially started a buddy system but
they didn't warn that they were raped
they just said they were attacks well
until we could actually confirm what did
what had happened on there through the
through the the investigation and
through the research of the specific
things it was very difficult for general
Johnson at the time to then say what
specifically happened until they could
let me ask you this now do you believe
that two cadets were raped on that trail
I don't know exactly what happened on
the trail but let me make it very very
clear Nora that whatever happened on the
trail the most important thing is that
those cadets get support and that they
get care and that their voices are heard
and they have an opportunity to talk
about some with someone to receive that
case do you think there is a problem
general at the academy when it comes to
sexual assaults and how it's being
handled do you think that there are
problems there I don't think there are
problems and let me tell you why is that
you talked about some of the reporting
of the numbers of sexual assaults I want
numbers of reports to go up I know that
doesn't make sense right on the surface
but I want reporting to go up we know
that this is an underreported crime we
know that across the nation and across
campuses this is underreported so I went
reporting to go up so that I can provide
that care provide that support last year
38 percent of the assaults that were
reported to our offices 30
8% were assaults that happened prior to
arriving at the Air Force Academy which
means someone Etsy and support for
something that happened prior to
arriving at the Academy that's why I
want to have that available to them that
support all right general Salaria thank
you so much for being here for this
conversation we really appreciate it
well thank you very much